you know i did want to ask you angelina
because you described playing this
woman as you know playing a broken
character who has to learn to stand back
up and that's part of her healing
take a deep breath
hold it
and lay back
i wonder at the time you decided to take
on this role why was this part something
that really spoke to you
and made you want to dive in well we all
have
times in our lives where we feel broken
and uh i was uh in a period like that
it's been
you know i've had my my share of of
things that have made me feel
um
you know hard to speak too much about it
but just overwhelmed
or broken and so to
to be kind of to have an opportunity i
feel very lucky i wish all women could
have this at times in their lives all
people could have this when you go
i've had it many times in my life when
my mom passed away i did wanted
you know it's part of something that
when you feel like you just want to
kind of hide under the covers or you're
not sure what you've got left in you
you get an opportunity and i would
encourage anybody to do it you're not a
film actor doesn't matter go somewhere
see what you got in you
put yourself against the elements or try
something you've never tried and
kind of try to rediscover that that
strength within
it's smart you had to find something
find some way some outlet to bring you
back
to a place so now what do you anchor
your self-worth in now
do i anchor myself worth it yeah oh
my use to others i think that's always
been you know certainly since being a
parent but i think before then just
you know contribution i think that's
what i try to tell my kids it's not
you can try a bit of this you can do
this with your life or that but at the
end of the day what's your contribution
what's your contribution to others
yeah you know i love that my dad said
if anything happened i should find
someone i could trust
are you someone i can trust
so how easily did you two bond uh you
know maybe off screen or some of the
things you did to really kind of feel
that trust with each other on screen
um well we would hang out some weekends
you know
if it whether it was um going airsofting
or stuff like that
but i feel like we just had a good
relationship on set because we were
working with each other
quite often we just sort of got
comfortable with each other and
went from there yeah wait wait what was
that air airsofting
airsofting we aren't exact it's like
it's like paintball except it's these
little
plastic pallets and we we did it on one
weekend with
um angie and her and her kids
um and just hurts a bunch but
just heaps of fun okay let's talk about
angelina like she's not in the room
how good is she at airsofting and did
she go down first or was she one of the
last people standing
i think i think i did pretty good
really good you did really good she was
she was all right
i'll give you that yeah you were good
you know angelina just hearing this
actually makes me think
um how tough was it for you to go back
for this character to like channel those
pre-mama days those pre-nurturing days
those pre you know because a lot of what
you do
is is being the woman that you are and
being the mother that you are to your
kids so
how hard was it for you to go back to
you know that person before
this whole life that you've had
well yes it wasn't just that she doesn't
have kids she doesn't really know or
i'm not even sure she likes kids so it
was really funny to be with somebody who
had um
that was the biggest note i got from
taylor like stop being so
you're being too nice to him you're
being too pathetic you're being too
right so
so then uh you know different things
like the dead to trip you and like
you know tripping a kid is just such a
weird feeling
you know you get into it but
uh yeah her language around him it was
it was weird at first and then it was
oddly freeing because you know
finn was so tough and so fun so it made
it easy for me to kind of
be really weird with him and beat him up
a little bit and be strange
and uh you know he knew it was okay a
different kid might have
might have got his feelings hurt or
found it me really weird but yeah he
found it funny so he had to throw some
he had to throw a couple of f-bombs your
way too
so yeah he can he can hold his own
[Laughter]
um so i want to ask this to both of you
finn i'll start with you
how good of a survivalist are you and
were you better were you are you better
now after doing this film than you think
you were before
um yeah i i think i'm
i'm gonna write survivors um but i
definitely think i got better
during this film um because i sort of
got to learn a bit more about the
terrain
of uh new mexico where we shot yeah and
learn a bit more about
the nature on set and because we're out
in the wilderness
a lot while filming so i definitely
learned a lot about
the country in the state angelina when i
when i look at you i do feel like you're
a woman who can hold her own but what do
you think about a survivalist and how
you how good
would you think you have been before and
now after you did this movie
uh i i think i picked up some things i
got better at my wood chopping and my
fire starting and my
repelling finn um let me ask you because
you did angeline was talking about that
moment when she had to trip you
in the film so how broken and beaten up
did you
did you come out of this film because i
know everybody had to have some rough
moments
um yeah there were a few it was it
wasn't anything too bad
um with you know stunts like that it was
mainly just
minor scratches bruises maybe a twisted
angle
that was that was all that was maybe a
twisted ankle that's not a little bit
i think it was melted with wood chips
from the helicopter was one of our
oh yeah that wasn't intentional but that
was one of the things
yeah sitting on the helicopter in a
scene and just the debris
from it was cool but
cool but um hard we ended up in a weird
hail storm together
what about you angelina because you i
mean i love seeing first of all i love
seeing you in an action film i love
seeing you kick butt for real
for real so what about you what was
maybe the toughest day for you
physically god i don't know i mean i
think
well the water was it was fun though but
it was i think the holding the breath
and trying to figure that out or the
fire but that was that was also kind of
fun you know i do
i do love an action movie i think and i
do love to
so it's not it's not it's not as hard
sitting still is hard for me